okay move out
you
you
in the spring of 1965 the first United
States Army combat troops were committed
to the conflict raging in South Vietnam
Viet Cong fearful of the new m16
automatic weapon called them the men
with the little black rifles Hanoi
Hannah called them juvenile delinquents
in green t-shirts they were American
paratroopers of the 173rd Airborne
Brigade and with fierce pride in their
outfit
they called themselves the sky soldiers
just back from Vietnam a freelance
correspondent documents the story of the
unusual breed of fighting men known as
the sky soldiers to learn their story he
lived with the paratroopers of the 173rd
Airborne Brigade followed them through
the steaming jungles and rice paddies of
South Vietnam where they have made
history the first time I saw them was
the morning of May 5th
1965
a seemingly endless stream of
big-bellied silver c-130s began landing
at Benoit airbase about 18 miles
northeast Saigon
along with other correspondents I going
to get down to cover the arrival of the
first u.s. army combat troops watching
them disembark he couldn't help seeing
that there was a special quality about
these men
young sure but the way they moved and
formed up without any confusion well
there was a feeling you get when you're
watching real pros they knew their
business after seeing them I decided
that I would stay in Vietnam and see
these paratroopers in action Brigadier
General Ellis Williamson commander of
the 173rd had arrived on the lead plane
asked how long before his troop would be
ready to begin patrols he answered
tonight as a matter of fact it was a lot
sooner than that in only a few hours
there was a perimeter guard about the
airbase
and patrols were moving out beyond the
barbed wire it was the first time in
more than a year that any troops had
made extended patrols outside the area
besides setting up brigade headquarters
at Benoit a task force was landed at bun
town it consisted of an infantry
battalion with engineer and medical
units and it's job was to secure and
defend that airfield
a few days later the rest of the
Brigades personnel and equipment arrived
by sea
they proceeded by road convoy to ban
walk now with all of its men and
equipment 173rd was set to get rolling
the next two weeks were spent in
sharpening combat techniques and
revising tactics these included Eagle
flight fast sprites on targets of
opportunity
and foot patrols in hostile areas
at the same time the armored troops and
the cavalry were making a show of force
on the network of roads and conducting
reconnaissance
once secured the roads came alive with
native transport for the first time in
many months the people of the province
could journey to market and visit
friends and family
the 173rd is a separate brigade meaning
that it's not part of the division
itself contained the first Airborne
Brigade to be so classified at that time
the combat units consisted of two
battalions of infantry
an artillery battalion with three firing
batteries a cavalry troop and a company
of armored combat support units included
a medical company a company of Engineer
a maintenance company signal and
communications units transport supply
and administration independence of
movement was provided by to the tunes of
truth carrying helicopter and a gunship
with two
with the Benoit area made secure
large-scale attacks against the enemy
were must the largest of these took
place at the end of May and employ
nearly all of the combat units in the
brigade
the infantry
artillery and cavalry
as well as engineers and the platoon of
volunteers from administration supply
and maintenance units it seemed as
though everybody wanted to get into the
act
the operation was strictly an infantry
type airmobile assault
the landing zones have been pounded by
the airport then minutes before the task
forces arrived army gunships at the
brigade made a final sweep the gunship
platoon nicknamed the Cowboys from their
radio call sign softened up the landing
zones our LZ then the first task force
long into action
it was made up of cavalry engineers
support troops and artillery their first
mission was to secure the L Z's for the
other two task forces the other two task
forces landed the first elements were
already in high gear the operation got
underway quickly and efficiently you had
to be impressed young as they work these
men move like veterans like pros with
years of experience officers and
enlisted men all worship a team you
don't get this good just by accident
there must be a good reason I haven't
yet discovered just what it was
almost from the moment this operation
began the sky soldiers met scattered
enemy resistance they have today for
four days the brigade moved ahead
sometimes through jungle so then you
could hardly see the sky other times
over fields where there was no cover at
all everywhere the insect and the heat
pressing down like leg
although the Vietcong were hard to find
and refused to hold their ground many
bunkers were uncovered
Vietcong base camps were rendered
useless and the supplies captured to
distribute to local villagers
at the end of the fourth day the brigade
was picked up and returned to Benoit
the only way to get to know an outfit is
to stay with it in camp as well as in
the field during the next few weeks
talking to the men gave me an
opportunity to learn the brigades
background and explained much of the
reason for its esprit de corps and its
efficiency in combat the 173rd was
activated June 25th 1963 around a
nucleus of the second airborne battle
group of the 503rd infantry the direct
descendant of the 503rd Parachute
Infantry Regiment known as the rock
which had jumped on Corregidor in World
War two
Romney's men they formed a balanced
airborne combat force it was the first
and only separate airborne brigade in
the United States Army for two years
these men under the command and guidance
of general Williamson and his staff have
been working and training together until
they'd been forged into a unique
self-supporting strike force capable of
handling any emergency anytime anyplace
these fighting men had trained in
Okinawa Thailand the Philippines and
Taiwan
they're jungle skills have been honed
razor-sharp and every last one was a
qualified jumper
airborne all the way
this was truly a crack outfit where
reenlistment often ran as high as 100%
and you can't get better than that
although the brigade mounted many
attacks in an area northeast of saigon
called warzone d which was supposed to
be an impregnable Viet Cong fortress
contact with the enemy was always light
and scattered the VC preferred to lose
large amounts of food and supplies and
to give up their bases rather than stand
and fight it wasn't long before the sky
soldiers found out why along with some
captured supplies documents were found
with red avoid fighting with the men who
carry the little black rifles unless you
have a much stronger force than they
have about this time the brigade took on
an international flavor attached to it
were Australian troops veterans of the
Malaysian campaign trained in counter
guerilla warfare
these battle-seasoned soldiers were a
welcome addition fitting right in with
the rest of the unit
these Aussies were assumed to be joined
by troops from neighboring New Zealand
in July war zone D was the scene of a
massive attack against the Viet Cong
Vietnamese soldiers fought side-by-side
with the troopers at the 173rd it was a
large-scale operation with the full
resources of the brigade employed
against the Vietcong when the 173rd
moves out on an operation like this 60%
of its support troops accompany the
combat unit
at first the fighting was light with
little opposition then it got tougher
the sky soldiers are tough aggressive
fighter and the deeper end of the jungle
they went the fiercer the fighting gun
wherever the enemy was too deeply
entrenched the artillery blasted them
loose General William since policy was
spending bullets not bodies the
operation lasted for days and was a
tremendous success there were more than
400 Vietcong casualties and 50 prisoners
captured over a hundred tons of weapons
and supplies have been taken
and thousands of documents captured
which proved to be a goldmine for
intelligence
the brigade moved on from success to
success for tui we're a get corn supply
route was destroyed Pleiku and consumed
in the central highland to let the siege
and clear the roads for an Arvind relief
column and the so-called iron trying the
Iron Triangle was an area where no
friendly forces had set foot for more
than a year air force strike
artillery fire and army gunships
prepared the way
then the infantry moved in sweeping
through the jungle
despite the fact that the enemy was
strongly dug in in many areas the sky
soldiers routed them out
and kept pressing right on
but in combat even the victors must
suffer casualties
fortunately the sky soldiers casualties
were light
the medics exposed themselves time and
again to care for the woman
Vietnam Dustoff is the affectionate
codename for the medical evacuation
helicopters and they perform miracles in
getting in and out of almost impossible
spot
it took six days to work through the
Iron Triangle but when it was over the
Vietcong had lost over a hundred men six
camps and thousands of pounds of
supplies and food the beds of the Iron
Triangle had been broken and was to stay
that way for over a year
as important as defeating the Vietcong
is the need to win the loyalty of the
Vietnamese people to this end the men of
the brigade applied themselves with the
same spirit they showed in facing the
enemy a well-rounded program of civic
action was initiated an important part
of it was routine medical treatment
the health of Vietnamese help themselves
heavy equipment was provided to build
and restore roads
the band volunteered their free time to
help in the construction of schools and
in educating that yet to me
food and clothing were provided for
villagers who had fled from Viet Cong
oppression
for the first time in more than a year
many of the villagers were able to go
freely to church one that the 173rd had
helped them to bill
sanitary wells were dug in villages that
had never had clean pure water
on their own time and in some cases out
of their own pockets the sky soldiers
undertook the sponsorship of orphanages
and help refurbish schools and
playgrounds for the children
one of the brigades most unique missions
was Operation new life for more than two
years the Vietcong had controlled the
rice harvest in this rich and fertile
area
the mission was to drive out the BC
restore government control and protect
the harvest in addition to the airlifted
troops long-range ground controls helped
to forge a long chain which grew tighter
as the troops swept across the area by
moving at night as well as by day the
173rd broke another myth that only the
Vietcong there the move in the dark by
such actions the sky soldiers began to
win the confidence of the local
population and to loosen the grip of
terror that the VC held over the
Vietnamese peasants
kindness and decent treatment of the
villagers as well as the work of the
Civic Action Teams resulted in bringing
entire villages over to the side of the
government
more than 300 Avicii were captured in
this operation and the local Vietcong
battalion defeated
for the first time in two years the
people of the region harvested their
crop without fear and the local
government could once again function
as proof of the effectiveness of civic
action and psychological warfare efforts
nearly 60 ralliers or defectors from the
Vietcong came in with their weapons to
surrender for the 173rd the missions
continued
there was Operation Marauder directed
against the VC battalion they defeated
the battalion and captured rosters which
identified every man belonging to the
local DC in operation crimp they
uncovered a VC base camp in ho Bo woods
which included a tunnel complex that was
three miles long and six levels deep
operation followed operation Dexter
Yorktown Aurora 1 Aurora 2 hardihood and
Toledo with little or no break between
operations operations Sioux City took
them back to zone D once again once more
the Vietcong avoided full contact
but large stores of clothing weapons and
other supplies were captured
the last operation I saw the 173rd
carryout was Junction City
this was to be the largest multi
division operation to date the target
was war zone seen near the Cambodian
border northwest of Saigon
the entire brigade was committed
but this time there was a difference
this was to be the first parachute
department by American forces in the
Vietnam conflict
the planes are bigger and faster today
but this is how it must have been when
the old five old third parachuted down
on Corregidor in World War two this is
how it is with the men of the 173rd no
one hesitates each one is raring to go
security was good but there was some VC
ground fire aimed at the paratrooper a
few of the jumpers found holes in their
chutes to bear this out but the only
injuries were a few sprained ankle when
the jumpers were on the ground the VC
really opened them the first job was to
secure the drop zone when it was secure
the c-130 began dropping the heavy stuff
equipment and supplies
operation Junction City was the biggest
in Vietnam up to that time
then of the 173rd did their job
all the way
I've often wondered what makes an outfit
like the 173rd airborne the way it is
part of it is due to the man who lead it
like general Williamson who was
responsible for organizing and shaping
and general Smith took command and get
Nam in 1966 followed by general Dean who
led to jump in operation Junction City
part of it is the training the top of
the going gets the better they seem to
like it mostly it's pride pride in being
part of an elite outfit of volunteer one
of the pros they don't brag but one of
their infantry battalions was presented
the distinguished Unit Citation by
general Westmoreland by the time I left
they had four Medal of Honor winners
among scores of silver stars and they
don't bother to count their Purple Heart
these are the men of the 173rd Airborne
Brigade separate airborne all the way
by now most of the men of the 173rd that
I knew have rotated the new assignments
the ranks are filled with new names and
faces but the sky soldiers are still in
Vietnam fighting and working to help the
Vietnamese people to build a free
society of their own choice and they'll
probably stay until the job is done
well done